enemy up ten a minute three to go fourth
quarter clock stops and norman touches
the ball and he does at the timeline
powell
into the lane
[Applause]
oh no nurkic
flicks a left hand out of tyler hero you
can't do that
and now they are separated quickly
[Applause]
and nerk has been kicked out of the game
it happened
when nerc set the screen hero fell to
the floor and nerk's roll was delayed
and i don't know if it was delayed
because he was talking or anything
happened there's the screen watch he
doesn't roll right away
there's a better angle let's see did he
say no didn't say anything he just left
and then hiro comes from behind and
pushes him in the back
so hero was just upset because he got
hit with a big screen
and it was good that nerd did not have a
closed fist he threw the left hand right
here
it looked like it was an open hand
[Applause]
hey guys we have a double ejection for a
fighting foul between nurkic and tyler
hero they both will be ejected we will
shoot two free throws with norman powell
and play
off of the second free throw
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
hero kicked out of the game nurkic
kicked out of the game norman powell to
shoot two free throws
and it looks like hero was somewhat
surprised by it
the ejection
it looks that way i don't know what he's
saying but
it looked like
like right even right now he's still
looking up
like i think he thought he was still
going to be able to remain in the game
well heroes 9 is done nurkic is done
hero was 16 points
and